[Music]
the last time where the philippine
president won the majority of the votes
in the relatively competitive elections
was in 1969 when his own father won a
re-election and few years later
essentially established a dictatorship
so this is historic in every deja vu
sense of the world now he is nonetheless
controversial precisely because of the
baggage of the father precisely because
of the disinformation that his campaign
has unleashed throughout the years to
paint those dark days of martial laws i
suppose a golden age
in the philippines
[Music]
one of the biggest concerns we have a
potential marcus presidency is that even
the past will be unpredictable forget
about the future the fear is that the
historical curricula in this country how
these issues of history the martial law
the marcus dictatorship are discussed
will be treated differently even by
mainstream media for fear of not
antagonizing the marcuses
[Music]
[Music]
throughout these elections there was
essentially cordoned sanitaire around
the princeling of philippine politics
right and the purpose of that is to make
sure that they minimize his exposure to
close scrutiny and minimize the
possibility for him to have some
rhetorical meltdown so the unity
motherhood statement essentially love
love love
all of that was a calculated move to
keep it as vague as possible but the
vagueness seems to have worked for him
because it made him look like someone
who doesn't want to get into petty
fights someone wants to stay above the
freight
almost someone mythical
[Music]
he's really winning this because of his
team up with very popular presidential
daughter sarah duterte who's even in a
more landslide victory situation in the
vice presidential race but the second
factor is i think the opposition didn't
play their card very well lenny
regretted opposition leader had
fantastic rallies she got alias
um you know celebrities and all of that
but it kind of looked like the hillary
clinton campaign in 2016. a lot of glitz
a lot of glamour not a lot of good
strategy a lot of blind spots a lot of i
would say tone deafness from software
supporters
[Music]
you